- WHERE IS HE?
- STANLEY.
- HUH?
- WHAT'S GOING ON?
- OH, COME ON, I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN CHEATING ON ME.
- YOU'RE BEING RIDICULOUS.
- ANDREA, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN [bleep]
A DOG BEHIND MY BACK.
- WHAT?
A DOG?
THAT IS INSANE.
- THEN WHY DID I FIND THIS
IN THE LAUNDRY ROOM, HUH?
[dog barks in the distance]
OH, MY GOD,
HE'S HERE RIGHT NOW, ISN'T HE?
HE'S IN MY HOUSE RIGHT NOW!
- WAIT, STANLEY, NO!
WAIT!
[growling]
- IT WAS YOU!
[screaming and struggling]
- [gasps]
- YOU S--OW!
WHAT HA--
AAH!
[dog yipping]
[growling]
- [exclaiming]
- AAH!
[screaming]
[dog growling]
[grunting]
- [mouthing inaudibly]
GO.
- COME HERE.
OH.
I SEE.
YOU...
NEED TO KNOW...
YOUR DOG RUINED
A TEN-YEAR MARRIAGE.
[dog whimpers]
AND YOU CAN GO TO HELL.
NO, HE'S CUTE, HE'S CUTE.
I CAN SEE WHY YOU LIKE HIM.